quails grails you're now watching Grails
Grails these is Grails too big to Grail
to Grail to Grail I mean you got that
grant money I got locked up
Braille you're now watching Grails to
show we're GQ and one of our friends
take you through the highest holiest
most untouchable pieces in our closets
today's episode is all about custom
pieces one of one today we have an
up-and-coming basketball player he's
really on the rise
guys don't quite ring your bell huh it's
okay it's okay I'm happy to be a part
you know well should we get into the to
the Grail all right let's do it
my custom Braille you know the theme is
custom is this Levi's Strucker jacket
and it represents all my favorite stuff
this is a Grateful Dead patch by the
artist Wes lang
I'm from the a so I've got the a
represented it's like your grandmother's
quilt you know it goes everywhere with
you no matter how many times you move is
always gonna be with you yeah just
always sewing another memento in the
gray love my grill I had my tailored cut
up a yeezus shirt that I got from
Kanye's tour in Australia aw I scarred
so he cut it up and so today yeah yeah
that's not quite fair I thought this was
like the United States only domestic
grill I thought is domestic girls only
you knew this without Australia jump
I didn't bring matthew dellavedova over
here I bring my mate okay
so my friend Curtis Coolidge very
talented artist who does love me
probably seen it on buildings both
legally and illegally did this jacket
for me this is a shot jacket this is
their perfecto
to put my initials on it which is cool
ladies like that you know sure I almost
feel like I've been left out of this no
one told me if I'm on my Harley Davidson
here today I have a question this is
your Grail but LeBron would you rock
that I will absolutely rock this yeah I
got a can in spider too
I got a crazy helmet with like a skull
on it everything I feel like that jacket
complements my my new feel I have a city
bike what's the team think about your
bikes oh man they like what are you
doing I'm like what you think I'm doing
I'm gonna breath of fresh air you know I
got one life with this man so yeah
that's what I'm doing
I don't have like cool initials where
girls like my initials or I don't have
those trillion Jesus patch so we should
just call it here yeah should we just
cut it how the thing is I don't think
it's fair you guys have outdone
yourselves why don't you look at it
first and then we'll let the viewers
decide okay well I'm just put this the
wonky out here like this is like you
know if you a parent that's like having
your first child if you an artist is
like having your first debut album it's
like painting on your first canvas so
I'm just letting you know how deep it is
it runs deep I'm just you know this is
like let me know what y'all ready for
the viewers to get to that point I keep
it right here imma keep it tough this is
like the holy grail for me
Wow Nike Air Zoom generation my first
baby Burke she burped I just burped my
baby on the head side of here I just
want y'all to see that with that say
with it it says 11 5 2003 first time I
stepped on a floor in front of my home
fans ever in the NBA I lost that game
not too happy about that but I won that
game if you know what I mean honey what
did you have the date customized into
him I won't open the box they surprised
me with it it was like my first home
game so they had already had to date in
there you know after the game I gave
them to our equipment guy and I was like
yo we casing these and uh I'm gonna keep
it forever I took these out of the case
for this I just want you guys to know
look look look at those it like oh my
god why yeah they warn't played hard
that night shoulda did that yeah I sweat
it out sweat it out sweat it this is
this is the holy grail for me
that's signature dunks that you have
where you basically put your chin at the
rim you're the only person that can
really do that that way but you've been
doing it from such a young age was young
LeBron thinking then this is my junk man
moment young LeBron was not thinking
that you know I remember kind of like
one of the first time I actually did
that dunk that's not like my dump man
logo we were playing on national
television my senior year and I got a
breakaway dunk I was just like see if
you can jump as high as you can spray it
out as long as you can as far as you can
and just flush it yeah but that's the
cool thing is because it just it came
from the flow and playing the game
organic organic organic type of guy man
catch me at Whole Foods whenever you
know saying catch me a Whole Foods if
you looking for me Whole Foods you like
let me see that right there that's that
cranberry potato salad let me see that
I'm telling you that's that tone of fish
with the cranberries on it let me see
that let me dump that in there just work
out that way baby let's see the
evolution we got the first I'm home game
baby I'm gonna sit you to it you ain't
you show the fret you said a favorite
now and then we get to this 413 we get
to the 13th question for you every year
drops kids go crazy you know celebrities
wearing other players on other teams
wear yeah but they're wearing you
sneakers aren't you everything works his
way back so when I was a kid and Isis
see guys where MJ shoes when they played
against MJ I was like oh ma got a little
mental edge over those guys so for me
now being a net that MJ class I'm like
if I see a guy wearing my shoes if he's
not like a good good real like brother
of mine cuz I got some guys that team
LeBron and that's all that's what we do
but if you just said god it was like you
actually go like to footlocker somewhere
or some
you just go get a pair of Brasi you want
to wear him on a Tuesday night versus me
will bust your ass straight up all right
guys that's it
grails now grayling is not a competitive
sport but let us know who had the best
Grail in the comment section would you
was it me was it ma G was it King James
it's up to you to decide thanks for
watching